salut c'est parti pour le deuxième jour
sur la méthode pour résoudre un rubik's
cube en moins de deux minutes et avec
maximum cinq formules et surtout vous
demandez pourquoi comme fond de décor
d'un sanglier et des potions alors non
je n'ai pas refait la déco de chez moi
c'est que je tourne cette série de
vidéos youtube space à paris qu'en ce
moment il ya les décors de game of
thrones je trouvais que ça allait bien
dans le décor ya commencé quittez vous
aviez appris à faire la première phase
et la première couronne daru x cube
j ai pas touché depuis déjà parce que
pour moi c'était pas hier c'était il ya
10 minutes
et aujourd'hui on va s'attaquer un petit
peu aux formules pour résoudre la
deuxième couronne il ya quelque chose
que je vous ai pas encore dit sur le
rubik's cube c'est que dans le langage
des gens qui font du rubik's cube
on identifie un sens de rotation le sens
normal de rotation c'est le sens horaire
et quand on tourne à l' inverse des
aiguilles d'une montre
on dit qu'on tourne en sens inverse si
je prends la face ce qui est à vous là
en ce moment cette phase là si je la
tourne normalement je l'attend dans ce
sens là dans le sens des aiguilles d'une
montre
par contre si je la tourne dans ce sens
là si je la tourne en sens inverse
et là vous vous dites d'accord mais
comment tu fais pour la phase du dessus
la face supérieure et bien de la même
manière
ça c'est le sens horaire et ça c'est le
sens inverse
et cette phase là comment je fais et
bessat c'est le sens horaire et ça c'est
le sens inverse pour déterminer le sens
horaire c'est très simple il faut que
vous vous imaginiez toujours en face du
cube que vous allez tourner jusque là on
a l'impression que je l inverse alors
que je vais dans le bon sens dans le
sens horaire si je place la face devant
nous on voit que c'était le bon sens
horaire et ça le sens inverse petitesse
de compréhension là pour remettre ça ici
en place cette fois ça va tourner dans
le sens normal ou dans le sens inverse
alain tourné dans le sens inverse où il
sera très compliqué mais je sais que
c'est beaucoup d'informations revenir
d'un coup c'est pour ça que je voulais
pas expliqué hier par contre hier je
vous ai dit qu'il y avait six endroits
qui ne bougeait pas qui était fixe
puisque c'est là que se fixent du
rubik's cube tels que monsieur rubik l'a
construit en 74
ce sont toutes les phases centrale celle
ci ça si celle-ci celle ci celle ci est
celle ci on va maintenant les
positionner en fonction de notre
première couronne dire que s'il ya du
orangis il faut que toute cette phase la
soie orange et comme les cubes centraux
sont fixes ici
il faut que ce soit absolument le cube
orange il est ici il faudrait que ce
soit la pub vers la le pub rouge
et si le cube bleu et je peux vous dire
que c'est pas le plus compliqué que vous
allez apprendre puisqu'il suffit de
tourner l'ensemble de ces deux blocs
jusqu'à temps que ça corresponde pour
votre face visible là c'est bon on a le
bleu sur le bleu donc automatiquement on
a le rouge sur le rouge le vert sur le
vert le orange sur le orange c'était
tout l'intérêt de créer au départ la
première couronne juste au retour dans
l'ensemble vous en avez placé quatre sur
les douze c'est quand même pas mal
il n'en reste plus que huit à placer la
seule couleur qui nous intéresse pas
pour le moment c'est la couleur jaune
puisque la couleur jaune
ce sera celui du dessus du cube qu'on
est en train de faire parce que
maintenant qu'on a réalisé la première
phase et la première couronne la
première phase on va la laisser en
dessous tout le temps on n'a plus besoin
d'y revenir vous vous rendez compte que
vous en avez placé déjà 4 sur les huit
vous avez fait 50% du chemin juste en
tournant un petit peu le rubik's cube
il nous reste quatre cubes place et
maintenant ce sont les quatre petites
couvre deux faces en même temps pour
faire ça on va utiliser une
identification et deux formules
possibles en fonction si on veut aller à
droite ou à gauche et deux formules
possibles qui se ressemblent vraiment la
première chose que vous devez faire
c'est placer au dessus d'un des cubes
centraux un cube de la même couleur
comme c'est le cas ici spontanément mais
on aurait pu en chercher un bleu ou un
verre et une au dessus d'un des centraux
en place et un de la même couleur et
c'est celui qu'on va chercher à déplacer
on va chercher à le déplacer sur la
phase où il ya la deuxième couleur donc
la phase orange qui est ici ce qu'on
souhaite faire ces déplacés celui ci ici
donc de l'emmener sur la gauche pour
l'emmener sur la gauche il ya une
formule
et qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit cette
formule à une audi au gauche en verser
aux gauches aux avants aux avoirs à
verser alors je vous écris la formule
juste en dessous et je vous propose une
méthode d'écriture quand je mets un
slash devant une lettre ça veut dire
inversée et si je mets une parenthèse ça
veut dire que toutes les lettres à
l'intérieur de la parenthèse sont
inversés donc on voit on inverse au en
inverse gauche ont fait eux ont fait
gauche ont fait eux ont fait avant on
inverse au en averse avant vous allez
voir que dans les doigts en plus c'est
assez facile à faire
donc on a dit que pour placer celui ci
ici il fallait commencer par faire au
inversée donc au inversée
je tourne
dans ce sens là puisque si je regarde
bien deux faces je vais bien dans le
sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
gauche l'inversé donc la gauche c'est
cet art est là inversée donc dans le
sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
aux gauches inversée s'est fait ensuite
aux normales et gauche
normal on vient d'appliquer déjà la
moitié de la formule est ce qu'on va
vouloir faire c'est isoler ces deux là
pour venir les chargés ensuite dessus
donc la suite de la formule c'était aux
avants donc au dans le bon sens avant
dans le bon sens
puis au inversée et avant inversée et là
on avait bien notre première couronne
qui était aligné le centre qu'on a place
au début de cette vidéo sans casser
évidemment ni la face blanche ni la
première couronne
mais qu'est ce qui se serait passé s'il
avait fallu placer celui ci à droite
mais comme c'est le cas pour lui
d'ailleurs bleu rouge ce bleu rouge va
là eh bien on a une autre formule qui
ressemble par contre à la première
formule c'est pour ça qu'elles sont
faciles à retenir
elle est facile à retenir parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'ils avaient gauche vous
vous direz droite
donc quand on va de ce côté là
évidemment on pense à la gauche qu'on va
de ce côté là on pense à la droite est
la grande différence par rapport à
l'autre formule c'est que tout ce qui
était inversée ne l'est plus et tout ce
qui était dans le sens normal et
maintenant inverser ce qui donne donc
aux droites aux droites inversée aux
avants inversée au havre ce sont
vraiment deux formules frangine et
encore je les identifie comme deux
formules mais on pourrait dire que c'est
qu'une seule formule mais bon j'assume
et je les intègre dans le fait de vous
avoir promis de retenir que cinq
formules j'ai mon bleu rouge ici et je
veux l'emmener là donc on a dit aux dans
le bon sens
droite dans le bon sens au inversée
droite inversée au inverser avant
inversée au dans le bon sens et avant
dans le bon sens et en même temps vient
de finir tous les bleus sans casser les
blancs et en respectant tout ce qui a
été fait précédemment sur la première et
la deuxième couronne on va terminer
d'ailleurs cette deuxième couronne ici
on a du verre orange donc je vais le
mettre le vert sur le vert comme on a vu
ça va à droite donc au dans le bon sens
droite dans le bon sens ou 1
rc droite inversée pour inverser pas
s'inverser au 1o dans le bon sens pas
dans le bon sens et on vient de finir le
vert le range s'est mis en place le bleu
aussi le rouge il nous manque que le
rouge
et là problème le rouge est là bas non
ce n'est pas un problème on va se
positionner du coup sûr le vert et il
faut qu'on emmène ce cube là ici donc on
va reprendre la première formule qui
était celle sur la gauche avec au 1
verset gauche inversée au dans le bon
sens
gauche dans le bon sens au dans le bon
sens avant dans le bon sens au inverser
avant inversée et on vient de finir sa
deuxième couronne guidon on n'irait pas
super vite
on vient de finir la deuxième couronne
donc vous avez vu les quatre du centre
était très facile à placer et vous
replacer les quatre qui sont à cheval il
suffit de retenir deux formules qui sont
assez voisines quand on retient lui on
retient l'autre assez facilement je vous
propose donc de vous entraîner
maintenant à faire la deuxième couronne
en plus de les retenir dans votre tête
vous allez comprendre toute la logique
de sens avant sens arrière et vous allez
commencer à retenir ça dans les doigts
c'est à dire qu'après vous allez même pu
réciter la formule ça va se faire tout
seul
ne perdez surtout pas votre motivation
demain on apprend la formule la plus
simple c'est une formule à trois
mouvements entraînez-vous bien amusez
vous bien dans la découverte de la
résolution du rubik's cube et rendez
vous demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mentale blog ciao
oui